i believe it's time for this to be taken
down
and perhaps we can put up a freedom
fighter
author alex weitzel is sickened by this
statue of henry tate
and wants it taken down along with any
others which honor racist
or colonial elements of britain's past
it just it just seems wrong that in the
21st century
i have to pass brits to the library and
see a bust of this man
who accumulated his vast wealth from so
much
misery so much death so much
tears and so much anguish the statues of
men who made their fortunes from the
slave trade and built the british empire
can be seen all over the country
not least in london where its mayor has
announced an urgent review of all
landmarks
triggered by the black lives matter
protests and the moment this statue
toppled
and the protests could be coming here to
whitehall
with calls for this statue of robert
clive to be removed
he played a key role in establishing
britain's colonial domination over india
and has been described as worse than
edward colston
some statues like that of william
wilberforce
who led the movement to abolish the
slave trade
will undoubtedly stay others have
already triggered debate
and even figures like charles dickens
who died 150 years ago today
illustrate the need for each case to be
carefully judged
some point to his use of racist
caricatures
while many see the social reformer and
opponent of slavery
we'll at no doubt be judged by people in
50
years time as completely inadequate
in our response to society to life and
all the rest of it nobody tried harder
than dickens
to improve the circumstances of his
fellow human beings
alongside the heated debate there are
also
calls for caution we cannot change the
past
but we can change the consequences of
the past
such as racism and we can change them
for the better
so the idea that you think you can take
a statute down and change
what happened it's a myth
but what does seem to be agreed is
alongside action
there must also be education about the
past
and its protagonists if we're to move
forward
lucy cotter sky news
you